I'm totally down for advertising on
Twitter I will sign up for Twitter blue
the moment he actually unbans the
political prisoners because otherwise
it's just like you know dude don't don't
it's Jack Dorsey all over again he told
me to my face we're going to create a
path to Redemption and then he never did
that they never had any interest in
doing it and it's it's insane because
why not just let Milo come back on the
platform like no seriously why not be
like hey you were banned for six months
we're sending this email to let you know
we're gonna restore your account and
we're asking you to follow these rules
if you don't follow the rules we will
just have to ban you again we're hoping
that you agree and then they'd get a
power user back but they're it's
ideologically driven they just want the
political victim but but Jack was you
know a symbol and and Jack also didn't
get rid of the human rights team
so so you know props to him because
again everyone's freaking out the human
rights they don't understand what the
team actually did the larger effects of
it and it was a net negative to everyone